I'm Brian Dolby at the ftth Council 10th
anniversary event in london where I'm
with Geoffrey andric Geoffrey you were
moderator on a plenary session today on
entertainment in the ftth era what were
the main sort of discussion points sure
um I think from a consumer standpoint
what what a tick away from the session
was that the consumers are becoming
increasingly sophisticated fragmented
and at the same moment they really want
they want what they want where they
wanted and when they want it and and of
course they may want all that but as we
all know the networks are beginning to
creak a little bit is there a feeling
was the description did that cover the
network it did in the sense that looking
forward and having you know some
assurance that as this content becomes
you know larger in file size more
sophisticated in interactivity needs
that that in fact the the bandwidth is
there not just for what's in the market
today but what's coming in the future I
say and I mean yourself you you work in
this field all the time without putting
you totally on the spot where do you see
the big changes in the home in terms of
entertainment in the neck sort of three
or four years I I think there's been you
know discussion in from sort of a
Hollywood perspective there's been
discussion for years about the decline
of DVD and in the home entertainment
that has historically been such a big
number in especially in the film side
and so what you're seeing is a decline
in DVD in some cases it's a little bit
slower to climb but it's still a decline
and then you've got this sort of you
know uptick in video on-demand streaming
online services and there's been a
struggle to sort of find the value
replacement for what's been lost in DVD
with what's coming in in the digital
world
and what's clear do I think everyone is
that that's that trend will continue and
people I think now are sorting out more
efficient you know models through a lot
of experimentation to be quite honest
but more and more you know viable models
to try to sustain that that that trend
okay so interesting times ahead yes
Chinese curse yes okay well thanks for
talking to us Jeffrey thank you very
much for having me so if you thought
you're up to date with your DVD racks
and collections maybe the time has come
to perhaps put some of that on ebay
times are changing
as it's moving faster